six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's go next to our caller
from the a 202 area code caller from 202
go ahead
what's going on David good good I don't
know what's going on in the background
if you're bowling or something but if we
are on speaker please do take us off and
it sounds crazy in there I'm using a
headset I'm outside right now I'm so
sorry the freezing winds right now
embossing pickles are hard items right
now okay but yeah my my question is
about it's about the national security
state I have been a civil libertarian
for a long time in a sense not a
hardcore one or anything general it was
very happy by Edward Snowden and all
these revelations however now that we
got Trump in office it's pretty much a
miracle there hasn't been a terrorist
attack or some sort of war or something
really substantial so really make him go
crazy as if he hasn't already but that
has made me have second thoughts about
this now I am a little more comfortable
with the idea of a national security
state purely because it might help
prevent some sort of terrorist attack
that would obviously draw some
horrendous overreaction from Trump so I
was wondering what your thoughts on that
I'm wrong to think that having a
national security state actually some
extent limits the potential that we can
have a terrorist attack well let's break
that down I mean specifically which
elements of a so-called national
security state are you thinking of that
you think might reduce the chance of a
serious terrorist attack mainly
primarily having access to tons of data
so most of stuff that Edward Snowden
revealed you know being able to go into
anybody Facebook accounts or
what-have-you know exactly what's going
on with certain people make that data
just available to them yeah but so
that's good good that you mentioned that
one so in testimony given before
Congress even the leaders of those
organizations said that there are no
specific terror plots that they can say
were disrupted because of bulk data
collection and the
techniques that Edward Snowden exposed
so I don't know if you're gonna argue
that doing more of that would prevent
the tax what would be your evidence for
that because I've not seen any well I
certainly have no direct evidence yeah I
hope to be completely wrong I mean I'm
Arabic myself the last thing I want to
do is go to an airport you know wanting
to be cavity searched every second yeah
I mean I think what you're asking is I'm
not criticizing what you're saying what
I'm what I'm saying is if we want to
play it out and say we're doing more of
this stuff prevent terrorist attacks we
don't have evidence that it does so in
so in that sense I think the answer
would be no well I suppose the reason we
might not have evidence just to play
devil's that is because there hasn't
been you know there hasn't been any sort
of major terror attacks there's
oftentimes or you know something gets
spoiled because there's an occasion to
intercept it or something like that
that's exactly what I'm saying
that's exactly in testimony when the
Snowden revelations led to hearings
about exactly the methods you're talking
about it's not that these intelligence
leaders said we have plenty of examples
but they're classified and we can't tell
you they simply said we have no examples
of such plots that were disrupted well I
definitely think you think there's a
chance they may be they're just saying
that that not optimize their their
resources are they obviously they're not
very trustworthy to begin with well in
that case then what would you even trust
as evidence but but no I don't have any
reason to think that that's what they're
doing thanks for the call really
appreciate it great to hear from people
in Boston